lino e questa era gratis come rovinare
l'infanzia a tutti a tutti parte 1 bella
a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigilia oggi siamo su ex
for burt che sarebbe un gioco horror dei
simpson che figo cioè nel senso di
horror noi abbiamo giocati tanti prodi a
tema simpson dovrebbe essere una fiducia
per uno ci sono due capitoli di tura
chapter one 24 uova devo trovare uovi
you gay
l'ex che ove c'è un gioco horror di
simpson è una figata incredibile non ho
mai appello lezzi porca vacca ma che chi
è roba [ __ ] è veramente yining yun bong
band ed ex formart sei tu bartz ceo non
sostiene sia accordo va bene devo andare
dentro e cercare le uova per bart
comunque la prossima tele uova delle
compri da solo e te le cerchi
soprattutto comunque va bene vado con la
torcia in terza persona è bellissimo si
è chiusa la porta bene ma è un horror ci
sono i job seeker geni ma porca vacca
che anzi avrò l'incubo per un sacco di
notti di fila
va bene stavo per dire margine sei un po
magra perché tendenzialmente e magra se
guardate bene dov'è mi sento camminare
ma non capisco da dove arriva il che
veramente orribile che bello maggie
medie veramente tenera problema è che
non so non capisco cento passi eccola e
magrissima e veramente mag anche cosa è
successo hai fatto dieta tesoro io devo
trovare uova per nostro figlio tra
l'altro pacchetto dovresti farmi paura è
che a questa è la simulazione ufficiale
di come sono le donne nel loro periodo
ecco sono così tutte aprono porte fanno
jobs che mangiano e basta ecco quello
ton donne col ciclo
io li devo cercare dentro le le cose in
chiaro se magari non urlare idiota ci
manca solo che urli cavalca non sono
allenato così tanto mica sono non
trattano alcuna regala una l'ho trovata
una sì uno su sei
va bene madonna che brutta roba dai dai
cerca veloce 2 su 6
io non riesco a capire dove margine non
lo capisco sento solo passi andiamo lì
sopra preghiamo iddio ok ti chiudi che
se la vede un po che perfetto allora
cerca cerca io devo cercare nelle negli
eau gene immobili o vi state messi
malissimo drogati qualche anno fa da
bart a cercarsele da solo ste nuova
maledette perché chi si è inventato sto
gioco malato
dunque sono tre su sei ragazzi la metà
le ho trovate è un casino prove
tutto calcolato ok mi è andata veramente
di culo però si va beh non è che può
andare in ogni stanza tua si riscontra
in questa sezione salti addosso progetto
dunque ha spento la torcia fatto una
prova incredibile si può spegnere la
doccia e geniale sto gioco è comunque
tre su sei veloce cerca cercare altre
stanze ma che non c'è non c'è niente
questa stanza vuota fantastico solito
mio vai vai cerca cerca 3 su 6 45 ne
manca uno marco huck difficilissimo
riuscito a trovarne 5 addirittura un
fenomeno
dai dai rega 666 lo devo trovare o devo
trovare nel cesso in eccesso libia house
minchia non ci credo non ci credo ci
voglio credere giuro secolo fosse già
faccio corri baiona vai veloce non ci
sono fatta ce l'ho fatta per le scale e
6 su 20 a 24 gen erano in totale stamina
ok round 2 dead 18mo rex to go a devo
trovare altre uova mi chiede partenza
brutta mamma mia se ci sono partenze
brutte questo è veramente la più brutta
ok l'altro altri sei che parlano poi
cercate da solo
minchia che due maroni
proprio dove non devi stare di vista di
mortacci tua sorella
vabbè delle tue sorelle anzi una draga
c'è qualcuno che piange non so chi
intanto io cerco 2 o demonio morto cosa
è successo ma non è successo niente ma
va a cagare
così dal nulla va beh grazie cioè
apprezzo comunque la mia domanda era ma
ci sono 18 uova nascosti in questo
momento ce ne sono solo sei adesso
quindi ce ne sono solo 6 nascosti tutta
la casa perché piange li mortacci sua
che fastidio
maggie maggie non è non è il caso non è
il caso di tai zitta ecco perché c'è già
è un casino
le fette trova marce su cazzi tua io ci
ho provato tutto quello che potevo fare
ho fatto non travasarli trequarti piani
quanto vuoi
se guardate bene telespalla bob ragazzi
se lo guardate se lo guardate in un
altro momento non questo stavo dicendo
che telespalla bob ai miei capelli
semplicemente questo volevo dire ma
niente è arrivato un jobs chiara enorme
1 trovato schifo dice pure perché devi
premere un miliardo di volte un casino
ca vacca mackie pianta lega nord io non
capisco
trovo difficoltà a capire cosa stia
succedendo lì non c'è mai cosa qual è il
problema perché mia rioni gems che non
c'è margine è entrato porca vacca che
palle posso uscire di qua sarebbe stato
bello che per caso anche bello posso
sfruttare dalla finestra ma che magra
che è ma che è successo vabbè io vado
faccio il giro con tra premi e mi spunta
1 caso ogni volta ma scusami allora non
c'è gusto eccolo qua non l'ho trovato
però il problema che anche se la evito
miss puntano a mi faccia caso di james
che devo fare
co demonio che palle ragazzo è
impossibile di sudando freddo è
difficilissimo devi stare zitta nuova
gamma devi stare stai zitta perché non
ho capito se è lei che piange che mi fa
venire infarto non so proprio angia caso
barca va controllato 26 oramai animi e
neanche una dieta che fastidio
già che c'è schiatto due molto bene 3
lo sento che c'è qualcuno sento visto
come me lo sentivo bene non piange e non
piangere porca eva ma se titoli non
piangere un piangere che rischio poi
sotto sotto sotto di essere pieno come
stai scendendo le scale spiegami scendi
scendi vai vai vai veloce lo stremo che
non pianga sperano bianca 3 3 3 3 3 dai
che sono tutti qua sono tutti quando
sento mai 4 buono buono 55 56 66 ti
prego direct 66 66
trovo vero botto vantava di beyonce
sociali ormai non c è ormai penale di
fatto cioè che l'ho mai fatta ce l'ha
fatta
gesù prega giuro non si vede da webcam
sto sudando orribile orribile cos'è che
massei bonn dove bar ceo nel bar
tutto a posto e cazzo stoffa ma io devo
seguire ma che sta succedendo quando e
dove march cosa è successo
ragazzi quanto e horror sto gioco le fa
eco al bar barbò ok entro io entro io va
bene così a caso mi dispiace anche a me
magari se ti muovi il culetto in sori
cosa a mi dispiace proprio così niente
porco demonio questa l'ho sentita fin in
gola orribile di infarto qua ce l'avevo
qua
ma ecco mancava al membro della famiglia
ci mancava insorge in tua sorella morta
che è sta correndo in casa dopo inizia a
farmi ridere non accetta come entrò in
casa entrava il coro si e no vabbè ma è
fattibile ha smesso di seguirmi sul
serio
no entra nel pavimento chiaro giusto
mi sembra ovvio fin troppo mi arriverà
ecco infatti mentre che avevo perso
apriamo giorni facciamo che basta basta
ragazzi mi sono rovinato l'infanzia ma
anche l'adolescenza ma anche la adultità
che comunque io ho sempre guardato
riguarda ancora i ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto
ricordatevi se parte se qualcuno vi
chiede delle uova
lasciate che se le prende da solo perché
è sempre un problema perché cosa ci
avranno ste uova
però ragazzi e video vi sia piaciuto
come sono pronto mi piace anche vari
social come iscrizione sono state voci
di schede non ci vediamo al prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]